it'll create it it's right there the
people in this room were the first to
see the universe through the eyes of the
james webb space telescope and they're
delighted the rest of us can now see it
too we've been working on this for 20
years or more and and i need to trust
the engineers who launched this into
space and built everything so i expected
this to go well
and uh and it has you should be prepared
to be wowed
this is a huge moment for the mission
engineers web is so big fitting it on a
rocket meant the six-ton telescope had
to fold then unfold itself once in space
that went without a hitch and now it can
get to work this is the flight control
room for the web telescope the only
place on earth with a direct link to the
observatory that's currently orbiting
the earth all the way out beyond the
moon
and on this monitor here a real-time
image
of the telescope's view into the
universe webb isn't just a better
telescope it can see things we've never
seen before planets beyond our solar
system and whether they have atmospheres
like ours the first stars that made the
molecules of all life and of course how
the universe came to be looking back
from today on earth our sun was born
about 5 billion years ago but the
universe itself made by the big bang
some 13.8 billion years ago while other
telescopes have looked deep into space
before we still know next to nothing
about this period a billion years after
the big bang but webb can reach that far
by seeing infrared the light from a star
for example 12 billion years ago has
taken so long getting to us it's
effectively been stretched by the
expanding universe from visible
wavelengths to infrared seeing that is
the only way to image the most distant
things in space
one of the most important tools for
doing that is webb's mid infrared
instrument its flight spare is in the uk
where it was built the challenge for its
designers keeping it cold if we don't
have the instrument cold all we're doing
is detecting its surroundings we need to
get it colder than the temperature of
the things we're trying to observe it's
just incredible to think that the
real version of this is attached the
james webb space telescope
a million miles from earth now
gathering that faintest light giving us
those first images of the oldest and
most distant objects in the universe
these new images are just a first
glimpse from the webb telescope it's
changed the way we see the cosmos but
over its anticipated 20-year lifetime it
will change the way we understand it too
tom clark sky news baltimore